TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Android Instant Apps
SDK 1.1 is now available,
with some highly requested
features such as improved NDK
support, configuration APKs
for binary size reduction,
and a new API to maintain
the user's context when
they transition from an instant
app to the installed app.
More details and
links to get started
are on the post linked
in the description below.
There are new features in
Firebase Test Lab for Android,
including Robo test
improvements, faster test
results, and support for
Android Test Orchestrator.
More details and
links are on the post.
API.AI is now
known as Dialogflow
and is still your
end-to-end platform
for building great
conversational experiences.
Recent launches include
an inline code editor
and multilingual agent support.
We recently released
TensorFlow Lattice,
a set of pre-built
TensorFlow estimators
that are easy to use,
and TensorFlow operators
to build your own
lattice models.
There's a lot of details here,
so I'll recommend you just
head straight over to the post
for a detailed explanation
with a video and graphs.
We recently released beta
gems for Stackdriver,
our monitoring, logging,
and diagnostics suite.
Now you can use Stackdriver
in your Ruby projects
wherever they happen to be.
The GitHub link is on the post.
The App Engine Firewall
lets you control access
to your App Engine app
[INAUDIBLE] set of rules
and is now generally available
and ready to secure access
to your production applications.
More details and
screenshots are on the post.
When we first announced the
rollout of the new AdWords
experience back
in March of 2016,
our goal was to introduce
a faster and more intuitive
AdWords that's focused on
helping you reach your business
goals.
This new AdWords
experience is now
available to all advertisers.
Getting started and
information is on the post.
We're excited to
announce that we're
offering a $50,000
Udacity scholarship
challenge in the United States
through the Grow with Google
Initiative.
To apply for a scholarship,
head on over to the post.
Please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for joining us this
week on the Developer Show.
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]